[Music]
this bar features a thick layer of milk
chocolate around a sweet salty and
crunchy peanut butter candy Center
making that peanut butter candy Center
is the tricky part to make the candy
part of it the factory combines liquid
sugar corn syrup coconut oil and
molasses they mix and heat these
ingredients for about eight minutes the
[Music]
cook candy is poured into a large
stainless steel bowl
[Music]
next they add leftovers from the
previous batch of candy
they call these leftovers rework because
they rework them into this new batch
[Music]
once the rework has mixed with a hot new
candy they empty the bowl onto a cold
stainless steel table
[Music]
they blend the candy until the two birds
into a sweet gooey mass they start up
the polling machine which stretches the
candy non-stop for about five minutes
this infuses the candy with air so that
its consistency resembles taffy rather
than hard candy then a pump draws piping
hi peanut butter from this tank and
deposited in a generous layer onto the
candy sheet workers round the sheet
between two rollers and feed it to the
rope sizer it stretches the peanut
butter candy into a rope that's the
exact diameter of the chocolate bar
Center the next machine makes a pinch
mark every 5 inches or the length of a
chocolate bar
the aroma is like a confectionery
carwash centers pass through a hot rinse
of milk chocolate first then an overhead
dryer blows off any excess as the bars
approach the rapping machine the in
feeder arranges them in single file
rolls of printed plastic film unwind
into the machines forming box in the
blink of an eye the machine folds raps
and heat seals the film around each
passing bar a revolving knife slices the
wrapper between bars then it's off to
the packaging Department where workers
pack them 24 - a box these chocolate
peanut butter bars are ready to be
devoured by anyone in the mood for a
crunchy sweet and salty chocolate snack